residentes franceses en bélgica han
votado hoy masivamente en esta primera
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
francesas se han desplegado un total de
11 centros de votación en todo el país
aunque el más numeroso ha sido el de
bruselas hay que tener en cuenta que los
residentes franceses son de las primeras
nacionalidades extranjeras de residentes
aquí en bélgica y eso se ha podido notar
muy claramente en los centros de
votación
de hecho el cónsul general de francia en
bruselas ha alertado de la gran
aglomeración que se ha producido a los
alrededores del centro de votación y de
hecho muchos votantes han lamentado que
han tenido que esperar más de cuatro
horas para poder ejercer su derecho a
voto además precisamente en bruselas la
situación se ha complicado especialmente
porque justo al lado del centro de
votación había justamente una exposición
sobre el continente asiático que también
ha acercado a cientos de personas
interesadas en poder acceder a esta
exposición por lo que se ha provocado
grandes aglomeraciones a los alrededores
del centro de votación y también en las
carreteras hay que tener en cuenta que
los residentes franceses en bélgica
siempre históricamente han votado
masivamente de hecho representan las
tasas más elevadas de participación de
franceses en el extranjero y esto se ha
podido notar muy claramente aquí en
bélgica